in ukraine authorities are warning that
moscow is gearing up for a new push in
the donbass region but it's not just the
east of ukraine causing concern
ukraine's border with belarus is also
seeing a troubling military buildup
western intelligence agencies say that
russian soldiers and weapons systems are
ready and waiting in belarus to open a
new front against ukraine something that
would stretch kiev's forces considerably
dw's nick connolly went to the border
region near charnev to see for himself
here on ukraine's border with belarus
you're never really alone
i'm not sure that drone is one of ours
actually
it is
but that's not a given it was a russian
drone attack from across the border that
started the war for these ukrainian
border guards on february 24th
they tried to keep russian forces on the
belarus side by blowing up the bridge
but the russians came all the same and
stayed for nearly a month
since the russians left in april the
shooting around here has largely been
restricted to exercises on both sides of
the border
the fear now among many ukrainians is
that russia's exercises in belarus could
suddenly turn into real warfare just
like they did in february
russian forces have never left belarus
instead their so-called exercises keep
getting extended
ukrainian leaders long said their
presence was just a distraction or a
bluff rather than a real threat but
recently russian troop numbers over the
border have risen and the tone from
belarusian leader alexander lukashenko
has grown ever more aggressive
ukraine's actions are also speaking a
different language
these images from the belarusian
government apparently show ukrainian
forces mining their side of the border
in recent days
much of the thousand kilometer frontier
between ukraine and belarus was barely
marked let alone defended before this
war
back then trips across the border for
groceries were to see a doctor or part
of everyday life
we used to go to belarus and they would
come to us
we all just got on somehow
i didn't even think a war like this was
even possible
who knows what's next
the war has taken its toll on many
family ties that span this border
many people here in the village have
relatives on the belarusian side
some of them have stopped talking to
each other because of the war
i believe ukraine will win eventually
it has to
we can't afford to lose
many locals here have given up their
jobs to try to make sure that holds true
you for on it
we have a security guard
a driver
shop assistance
locksmiths
constantine's life changed overnight he
was called up but in charge of dozens of
men in the territorial defense force his
experience some brief military training
at university he'd never actually fought
people in other places can't know what
it feels like when bombs are falling and
your child is terrified of everything
most of us here have never even been in
a fight until the war
and then when it starts you know if the
enemy comes
you do what you need to do
without thinking twice
the atmosphere here might seem relaxed
and domestic with neighbors and even
fathers and sons serving side by side
but the real sense of threat is never
far away
costington tells us he's never yet had
to call her family with news of a
fatality it doesn't sound sure it'll
stay that way
and i'm joined now by katya glad from
the center for european policy analysis
she's an expert on belarus and russia
thank you so much for joining us um as
we know and as we've heard belarus has
long served as a staging ground for um
the russian invasion of ukraine
but are the people in that report now
right to fear that belarus could become
the latest front in the russian
offensive
yeah good morning sarah i think there
are certainly signs that there has been
an increase in military activity um
along the border with ukraine and
belarus
we know that they have been
certain
russian equipment brought back to
belarus particularly around two airports
not far from the border with ukraine we
have also seen uh some preparation for
mobilization like efforts we heard for
example that in one area in the south uh
men were um asked to show up for a
potential military draft and obviously
lukashenko also said um several days ago
that belarusia
will always support russia but on the
other hand even lukashanka's rhetoric
has been a bit ambiguous because he was
also trying to say that this is not our
war that we are fighting so i think at
the moment we don't really know whether
these are the signs for lukashenko to
show his loyalty to putin and to show
preparedness to fight but actually avoid
doing so or whether it is indeed a very
uh gradual
um
engagement of belarus into the war we
know that the kremlin has been quite
active in other spheres to drag belarus
slowly in the
uh processes which are they interested
in but at the same time the fundamentals
remain the same belarusian army is very
small it's poorly trained it has no
combat experience so most military
experts think that even if belarus
participates it would be to a very
marginal degree more like in some
subversion um intelligence efforts um or
likely to again protect the russian army
in the rear rather than participating in
a full-scale invasion
how about the people um within belarus
um
how do they view the war in ukraine do
we do we even know
um and are they worried about getting
further dragged deeper into the conflict
yes there are some independent polls
which are now mostly conducted through
the internet so they really cover people
who only have access to the internet but
um by all the statistics available it's
over 80 percent of the belarusian
population and the picture there inside
belarus is actually quite different from
what we see within the russian public
for example a few days ago two polls
came out which
confirmed the trends that over 85
percent of belarusians are against the
belarusian armed forces um being
deployed to ukraine and that has not
really changed um since the beginning of
the war and this is probably also um
what prevents lukashenka from
agreeing to give the belarusian army to
putin because that would be devastating
for him politically and people even
within the regime of alexander
lukashenko himself are very likely to
think the same what the belarusian
public think that this is not the
belarusian war and it is really shame
that belarus is part of that
thank you so much karcia glad as we
mentioned you're joining us from the
center for european policy and analysis
thank you for sharing your expertise